لعنة الله ، يا إلهي ،
القوات الأمريكية ليست معتادة على أن
تكون الطرف المتلقي لهذا النوع من
القوة النارية ، فهم عادة هم من يقدمونها ،
أعني أنه لم أكن خائفًا يا مايكل
في الوقت الحالي ، لكن هذا
شيء لم نكن مستعدين له
جاهز هو أن يكون جاهزًا لنوع من
الهجوم البري من قبل وكلاء إيران الجاهزين
لقذائف الهاون والصواريخ ، لكن هذه القاعدة
غير مجهزة للدفاع ضد
الصواريخ الباليستية في أي ليلة أخرى
،
كان من الممكن أن يكون بعض من ألفين ونصف جندي ومقاولين في  المناطق التي
أصابتها الصواريخ الباليستية
بدأ الإبلاغ عنها في غضون ساعتين
قبل الحدث ، وفي تلك المرحلة
كنا نكافح حقًا لأنك تعرف
كيفية الحماية من ذلك ، لذا فقد كان الأمر
يتعلق بالتشتت الذي تعرفه
وضع مسافة بين الأشخاص و  ثم
نقله أيضًا إلى مخابئ محصنة
فقط لتوفير تلك الحماية في
الساعة 11:00 مساءً  أولئك الذين بدأوا في
الاحتماء والمخابئ التي بناها
عدوهم السابق ، هذا
هو مخبأ من عهد صدام حسين ، لذلك شعرنا أننا سنكون
آمنين إلى حد ما هنا لأنه تم
تصميمه ليأخذك إلى معرفة نوع من
الضربة أو تم بناؤه  لأنك تعرف
الصواريخ الباليستية في الساعة 134 صباحًا ، سقطت الصواريخ الأولى
، وفي كل مرة يصطدم أحد
الصواريخ بالأبواب ، كان نوعًا ما
يغرق في عشرات الجنود كانوا لا يزالون
في العراء ويحتفظون بمواقعهم
لحماية القاعدة.
من الصواريخ القادمة وقذائف الهاون
والطيارين الذين يشنون هجومًا بريًا كانوا لا يزالون في
محطاتهم يشغلون طائرات بدون طيار لأنني
أريد أن أمضي قدمًا عبر الحصى ، نظرت
إلى الخارج مثل السماء الشرقية وأرى أن
هذا خط برتقالي ، لذا بدأت في الانطلاق في
صراخ الدخل وتحذير الجميع
من نوع ما  ثم ضربت
ألسنة اللهب التي ابتلعت أماكن سكن فرق الطائرات بدون طيار ،
لكان هناك حوالي ثلاثين جنديًا
ينامون هنا لو لم
يكونوا مستعدين ، واندفع آخرون حول القاعدة
بينما سقطت الصواريخ.  ملك لأي
شخص قد يكون مصابًا بفحص
دفاعات القواعد على طول محيط القاعدة ،
حارب الجنود الشباب في جولتهم الأولى غريزة الفرار وذكر أن
مانينغ أبراج الحراسة كان
مخيفًا بالتأكيد في البداية ولكن كلانا
عرف أن لدينا وظيفة يجب القيام بها  إدارة
البرج مع إبقاء أعيننا في المقدمة ، لذلك كان علينا أن نفعل
ذلك أكثر من أي شيء
يركز على ذلك للتركيز على كل شيء
خلفنا عندما ضربت إحدى الضربات قريبًا جدًا
، قفزوا في الجزء الخلفي من شاحنة
وحافظوا على موقعهم هناك ، كانت
ليلة على عكس أي شيء هنا  لقد
جربوا المخبأ لمدة ساعتين غير قادرين
على الرد على بعض المحاصرين في المخابئ
التي لم يتم بناؤها لتحمل الصواريخ
مثل هذه الأنواع من المخابئ الصغيرة
الموجودة في جميع أنحاء القاعدة ولكنها
تهدف إلى الحماية من الصواريخ
وقذائف الهاون والصواريخ الباليستية التي  تم
إطلاقها أقوى بحوالي 3000 مرة
من الانفجار الذي أحدثه هذا الانفجار
الذي تسبب في سقوط أربعة أطنان من جدار T ولكن
إذا لم يحدث ذلك ، فإن أولئك الذين كانوا
يحتمون  هنا ربما لم يكن
ليبقى على قيد الحياة ، فقد طغى الخوف من اكتشاف
من قُتل أو جرح
على الصدمة السعيدة من أنه لم يكن هناك
أحد يشبه ما يشبه لم الشمل
عندما ترى شخصًا
قريبًا منك وتدرك ذلك
كلاكما على ما يرام ، إنه شعور دافئ
في أعماق القلب أن جميع أصدقائك
عائلتك هنا بخير فقط شعرت به
إلى الأبد منذ أن رأيت رفاقي وأنت
تعلم أن هناك الكثير من العناق والكثير
من الدموع والكثير  إنه مجرد
شعور رائع أن تعرف أن جميع
أفرادك بخير وهذا هو المكان الذي
اعتدت فيه على ذلك ، فهذه غرفتي ذات
مخطط مفتوح أكثر قليلاً الآن ولكن نعم
كان سريري في الزاوية تمامًا
هناك وهذا هو جارتي
من الواضح أن كل شيء ذهب هنا ، إنه
سعيد فقط لم يكن أحد بداخلك ، تعلم أنه
نوع من الفظاعة بالنظر إليه مثل هذا ،
نعم إنه أمر سريالي أنا لست منزعجًا
بالنظر إليه ، أنت تعلم فقط أنه
تهديد تذكير لا يزال موجودًا أعتقد أنك
تعلم أننا نملك  بعضهم البعض  r لقد التقينا ببعضنا
البعض في تلك الليلة ، هل هذه
أخوة لم نقطعها أبدًا
لأنها تغير وجهة نظرك في
الحياة ، هل تفعل ذلك ، هل يمكن أن تعلم
أنها قد تنتهي في لحظة تعرفها
يجعلني حقًا قيمة قيّمة ، معظمها من
فريقي ، القاعدة لا تزال في حالة تأهب قصوى ،
مرفق الطعام مفتوح ، لكن الناس يأكلون في
مكان آخر لتجنب حشد كبير
من الجيش يقول إنهم
مستعدون لما قد يأتي بعد
ذلك ، يواصل وكلاء إيران على الأرض التعهد
بالانتقام  حتى بالنسبة لأولئك الذين رأوا الحرب
قبل ذلك لم يكن مثل أي تجربة أخرى في
ساحة المعركة ، فإن
الشعور الغامر بالعجز الذي يأتي مع
التعرض لهجوم صاروخي باليستي
ليكون تحت رحمة العدو الذي
يمكنه الضرب مرة أخرى حتى لو لم يكن مثل
هذا Arwa Damon CNN  قاعدة الأسد الجوية
العراق